[Music]
Kim Kardashian and Kanye West had a
scary Friday morning and it just like
hit me like where the biggest target
ever a spokesperson for the Los Angeles
Police Department confirmed to et that
around 510 on Friday morning they
received a call about a car theft on the
couple's property the spokesperson told
ET that a witness saw a suspect enter
the car and take personal items before
exiting the car and fleeing the scene
adding that a second suspect who was
hiding in some bushes also took off as
of Friday morning no arrests have been
made but the investigation is ongoing a
source close to Kim tells et that the
car belonged to a staff member not Kim
or Kanye and was parked at the bottom of
the driveway according to the source the
thief tried to take something from the
car and was startled by multiple
security guards with guns drawn
meanwhile another source tells et that
Kim and Kanye's neighbor comedian Kathy
Griffin also had items stolen from a car
in front of her home on Friday morning
the burglary comes just one year after
Kardashian was robbed at gunpoint in
Paris it just opened up my eyes that
this happens and that there's you know
really bad people in this world I could
still live my life but just on edge
[Music]